justement les jeunes impliqués en
politique on a décidé d'élargir un petit
peu le spectre est pas se limiter aux
républicains avec nicolas landry bonsoir
de la rédaction de tv 78 sur
l'engagement politique des jeunes dans
le département des yvelines déjà quels
sont les différents partis politiques
qui sont présents auprès des jeunes dans
les yvelines et bien grégory
nous avons répertorié au moins un set
groupes politiques vous allez les voir
apparaître à l'image on retrouve les
jeunes républicains les jeunes avec
macron génération nation soixante dix
huit pour le rassemblement national un
mouvement qui a changé de nom mais qui
est né avec le front national dans les
années 70 dans le département nous avons
aussi des jeunes générations point s du
mouvement créé par benoît hamon en
juillet 2017
il ya aussi les jeunes communistes le
mouvement des jeunes socialistes des
yvelines relancer au mois d'août puisque
ce mouvement était en sommeil depuis les
élections de 2017 et enfin les jeunes
démocrates du modem
concernant les mouvements jeunes de la
france insoumise et d'europe écologie
les verts
tout se passe finalement au niveau
régional qu'est ce que c'est être
aujourd'hui un jeune engagé
politiquement car un jeune engagé
politiquement en moyenne entre 15 et 30
ans
c'est un militant engagé sur le terrain
pour recueillir les revendications des
citoyens comme un relais pour le parti
c'est aussi un engagement pour des
valeurs des idées et une idéologie
politique défendue par leur parti on va
les écouter
aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement pour
lequel on a vraiment envie de se battre
qui en fait défend énormément les
intérieurs de la jeunesse qu'on va faire
remonter des informations et des jeunes
mis en contact avec des jeunes on doit
faire remonter au gouvernement et aux
élus locaux
c'est pas les enjeux aujourd'hui depuis
metz les motivations des gens très très
concret tant liée à des inégalités
sociales et économiques connaissance les
jeunes s'engagent dans notre mouvement
ont lutté contre un système qui exploite
les pauvres au profit des plus riches
alors à côté de leurs convictions
certains jeunes s'engagent aussi pour
leur avenir l'évolution de la société on
l'a vu notamment avec les manifestations
des lycéens pour défendre
l'environnement
on les écoute je pense qu'en tant que
jeune on a des on a des vrais sujets de
mobilisation je pense par exemple aussi
à l'écologie c'est bête mais on nous on
est la génération qui
devoir vivre en fait avec le dérèglement
climatique qui va devoir trouver les
réponses à ce problème là état de
déliquescence l'état d'insécurité puis
même de faim de fracture sociale dans
notre pays on peut pas en étant je pense
jeunes restés inactifs face à cela parce
que c'est quelque chose qui va nous
concerner directement